[Music]
there is a period in everybody's Journey
where they are so different because
they've started to do new things that
they no longer fit in with their old set
of friends but they're not sufficiently
developed that they've gained their new
set of friends and all of my friends are
taking the piss oh I'm not drinking
again too good for us are we not going
out again this week oh okay well like
enjoy staying in home and reading and
that lonely chapter that's in the middle
is something that I I would say almost
nobody that I've ever met who has gone
from a place where they are to a place
where they want to be hasn't gone
through